[Applause]
I'm it's Mark
the last ones what are we the last ones
what order are we supposed to be in
thank you you have been working hard
somebody repeat the order so we can get
in the right order for us
all right let
hello
order we're supposed to stand in again
can you read it out
okay okay you want you just won Oscars
you can do whatever you want on stage we
don't care nothing all right throw out
some questions over here guys
which actor threw up the most during the
plane flights anybody to the sun okay
one for one followed by one eight seven
right over here guys one four one
congratulations thank you
um okay so during the production of this
film a lot of you couldn't work together
in the same room because of covid can
you talk about a little bit about that
experience and then what it's like to
get to celebrate together tonight
we've got a signer
um Chris I I'd like to address that
during the production of the film I'm
the production sound mixer it was
pre-coveted we actually Shot the movie
five years ago so we're doing the
production of the film we all could be
together during post-production is when
the pandemic happened and these guys can
address that yeah we we we got the call
we got the coal and
um we were in lockdown in the UK so we
were asked the post team in the UK were
asked were we ready to just go through
the whole it was it was all new to all
of us what was what was going to happen
in post and we were just given all the
details of how all the social distancing
all the routine we were going to have to
basically enforce and it also involved
when Tom Cruise and Chris Macquarie and
everybody turned up in the dub so we're
mixing away on the stage at twicken and
film studios and we basically just had
to
it was all new and we just had to make
sure everybody was safe the days were a
bit shorter than normal which was
fantastic for us because we work
ridiculous long hours usually and it was
just a safe a sort of safe environment
was created so that we could
um mix the film and feel comfortable so
people could come in we would reduce the
numbers normally our dubbing Studios
might be 12 15 20 people in there for a
review of a reel but it was down to six
seven so we were just being very safe
and luckily we got through it and
um
um the rest is history
at the right time thankfully
next number moving on to 187 followed by
a question in the virtual Press Room 187
isn't that uh yeah that's murder isn't
it to your left 487 hello to your
your hi okay hi
you know many people credit Top Gun with
saving movie theaters and getting people
back into a dark place to see a movie
collectively and of course she did so
well financially so you have all that
under your belt what is the Oscar on top
of it mean a lot of people were hoping
maybe you'd slip in with a little more
but you got it for sound so tell us how
you feel
you know we have to be uh we have to
acknowledge our filmmakers who knew
before covid before anything when
they're still working on the script they
knew that this had to be special
um you may have heard at one point Tom
uh told Tom Cruise told Joe kazinski
this film has to be a bullet hitting a
bullet it had to be
uh perfect and it had to supersede what
the original film did which was already
an amazing film and so the expectations
were
very elevated and so throughout the
process it was how can we make this
better from story to production to sound
and so we all worked very very hard to
get it to the point to where it met the
expectations that Tom Cruise had set for
this film and so we are grateful that
sound won an award but so many of the
crafts including the story including the
directing including what Jerry
brookheimer put together with Tom and
Chris McCrory uh deserve amazing credit
for for making theater cinema something
that people wanted to risk and invest in
again we're so thankful for that
it means a lot
yeah to conclude
okay next up we question from the
virtual Press Room San Diego County News
you're on
hi can you hear me yeah
yeah okay good
um given that military aircrafts produce
different types of noise levels did you
face any challenges recording these
sounds for the movie
I I had the benefit the pleasure early
on to get to spend a week on an aircraft
carrier with these Jets we had f-18s and
f-35s and they're loud loud loud engines
and machines we have equipment that we
set up to
um to be able to record them but the
intention with this film was to be able
to experience Top Gun the way you
experience a jet when you're with it and
you feel it in your stomach you feel it
in your gut it has punch and it has heft
so we collected as much material as we
could and then thanks to our amazing
re-recording mixers and our sound team
we were able to recreate that for the
cinema and thanks to Dolby who gives us
subwoofers and gives us surround sound
and so the idea was what the pilots feel
when they're with a jet could be
experienced by the film goer
I'd like to also address that question
because I was a production mixer and I
would record these planes and it would
sound like it was distorting
I was like wait is it being overdriven
and I would take my headphones off and I
say no that's what it sounds like
because these jets are so loud they're
actually I don't know they're like
shattering the air or something because
right would you agree out it's like
something almost like they're tearing
the air apart
ripping and uh you know so at first I'm
like wait is am I overdriving this stuff
I'm like no that's what it sounds like
they're and they're so loud like at
times I was there's a shot where Tom's
riding his motorcycle and the plane is
taking off simultaneously and I was in
between the two runways and it was so
unbelievably louder I was like wow this
is loud and you could feel the heat from
the engines too anyway that's my answer
that question next
somebody okay next up we have 321
followed by final question 272.
hello I am Gemma from litter boxed the
film social network congratulations on
your Oscars we have another prize to
present to you tonight as of this moment
of the 10 best picture nominees top gun
Maverick is the most obsessively
re-watched film among our membership
yeah
somebody described the uh the measure of
re-watchability as being like a great
song like a great dance song when the
drop comes and you know the drop is
coming and you get that again and again
and again when you re-watch the film so
I wanted to know what your thoughts on
that are and what your message to the
audience is who have rewatched your film
and are still doing so great that's a
great question I think
keep going back and watching it in a
cinema for one
that's the first point watch it again
work again and again there's gonna
be something you get every time I think
the one thing about this movie that made
people want to go back and see it again
was that it was something you could only
experience in the cinema to that level
and that there is an emotional structure
to the soundscape whether it's music
sound effects dialogue it all fits in a
way that carries you through the movie
so you're set up for the next thing and
people like to be told a story that they
feel they can trust that they feel
engaged in that they're immersed in and
so that is almost it's addictive it's
like you want that feel good and not a
lot of films concentrate on that as much
these days films like to challenge they
like to they like to overwhelm but this
for me this soundtrack and this movie
brought the audience in and and immersed
people so you lean into it you're not
thrown away from it uh and so I hope
that people will continue to go and
watch it for that reason and
thank you for that honor yeah yeah thank
you thank you thanks and two seven two
final question of the night
Carolyn jardina from The Hollywood
Reporter hi congratulations hi thank you
wonderful work
um this is the third year since they
recombined the category into best sound
and there's currently a limit on the
number of you that can be up here you
obviously had a big team on this movie I
was curious uh do you feel like the
number is Right would you like to see
the um the number extended so there
could be more people in your category
and is there anything you'd like to say
to your team sure I would say it would
be great if it was a little more
flexible so that you could you could
allow people who had a contribution
in if it was warranted and I think that
in this case it was but you know rules
these rules and that's the way it has to
be uh there are some things that will
that things keep changing and uh the
size of movies keeps changing and the
community that makes those movies keeps
changing so I trust the academy to
totally understand how the how the
balance has to be but they need feedback
from the likes of us and all the other
sound teams to understand what it is
that we perceive as fair and right and
that's so it's all our responsibility to
make sure that everybody gets the right
attention and the right kind of
acknowledgment
I like to say that I've actually
addressed this before with the academy
because I wanted to promote some shared
credits because so often a movie is shot
half in England half in America half
here half there but the academy at least
in terms of production mixer for
traditionally will only allow one name
and for years I've said why can't we
have shared credits but they'll only
allow one so we'll see maybe we can make
some some Headway now because it seems
like things are really changing at the
Academy the last like you know five ten
years so
maybe but but we would love to see 20
sound editors up here
it's a lot of statues but anyway I I do
there's it's a valid question and it's
good
it's being considered so much and
congratulations on your big nights